[Music]
let's ask joseph what he thinks about
this joseph are you team nevada or
nevada how's it going i am in henderson
nevada yes very close to nevada maybe
five to ten minutes yeah there we go all
right
all right what's your question joseph
hi so i'm 17 years old i'm just starting
my life hey speak directly in your phone
for me joseph you you got a little
squirrel hear me there we go can you
hear me yes so i'm 17 years old and you
know i just got out of high school
graduated and i have a total of three
thousand dollars saved up and my friends
are pressuring me now
to get a credit card and my uncle's a
huge dave ramsey fan and i started
listening to dave ramsey behind that and
when i get off track i listen but
everyone's pressuring me now to apply
for that nevada state bank
city double cash card or whatever it is
and i'm very strict on no i don't want
to do that even my own mom
has been trying to convince me of you
know you can apply for a credit card and
they don't have a very good i mean 10
years ago
now they're much better i mean granted
we're in a way better place than we were
10 years ago we were in so much credit
card debt we didn't go on vacation for
seven years we paid it all off and now
all we owe is our house mortgage and
that's all the debt that we have left
but yeah that's they're all pressuring
me and i just don't know how to respond
to them and then
another thing is you know i want to be
on the path toward not having to waste
10 years of my life being stuck in this
miserable desert not going on vacation
so i want to be able to be wealthy all
right so joseph let me let me make sure
i'm understanding you're convicted
and convinced because of that conviction
that you're not going to get the card
you just want our advice on how to tell
them to shut up
pretty much and how to stay on track
yeah well number one sell the friends
that's an easy start right there you
know dave's always saying tell the car i
think we got to sell the friends oh gosh
sure you can't sell people well in the
words of ken coleman you tell him to
pound sand and kick rocks yeah so here's
what i would say joseph so joseph is
there anything
in their pitch to you that is tempting
you
anything about this tell me because
that's what i think you're getting at
you're like i need to tell them but then
i need to stay on track so what's
tempting you tell me about this double
points credit card whatever what is
what's tempting you
well the biggest thing that tempts me
out of everything is the fact that you
know
the whole issue with the credit score
because my brother brought up the fact
that you know when you buy a house or
when you're all right so joseph i'm
interrupting you because we only have a
few minutes a few seconds left george
tell them about the credit score so uh
i'll just steer you to this podcast
episode we did on the fine print called
the dirty truth behind your credit score
i want you and all your friends and your
brother and your mom all sit down and
listen to this because i'm telling you
i've lived without a score for many many
years i bought a house without a score i
paid cash for cars you can live without
a score i want you to build wealth not
your credit score that is going to be
your long-term plan to success my friend
joseph you just heard it from no score
george that's what they call me in high
school
mostly because i did not score in any
sport ken we brought it back i'm glad
you clarified that
joseph here's the deal you know what you
want to do you want to know you know the
life you want to live just say thanks no
thanks i don't want to talk about you're
making me feel uncomfortable fake the
snowflake move
everybody takes care of the snowflake